Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE
radical Republican congresswoman,
said yesterday that Tucker Carlson's filing
firing by Fox News was illegal. Now, she doesn't
use the word illegal, but it's really important
to understand when these people on the right say
that was a violation of the First Amendment.
They are saying that it is against the law,
what took place. We're going to look at a video
clip of Marjorie Taylor GREENE explaining,
I guess, her perspective, if you can call it
that. What is really important to understand
is that when she says Tucker's First Amendment
rights were violated by Fox News, she's saying
it was an illegal firing. These are the people who
hold as one of their most important stated values,
low business regulation. Let businesses
do what they want to do. Law and order.
We need to unburden businesses from government
limitations. They should be allowed to do what
is best and most profitable for them. And
here, she says, a firing by a private company
was unconstitutional and therefore
against the law. We're going to break
it all down. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: Big news of the week.
Fox fired Tucker Carlson. Fox has gone
left. They've gone. Woke. We're clearly
calling them out for it. Tucker is a great voice.
Speaker 4: For conservatives across the country.
Speaker 2: He doesn't have the platform anymore.
When you weigh in on Fox's decision to fire,
probably one of the more conservative
voices, most important voices in America.
Absolutely. I think it was devastating to
our First Amendment. Eric, I see it as a
very serious problem. Our First Amendment is
free speech, but it's also freedom of press.
And when a gigantic media company like Fox
News fires their number one. Tucker Carlson,
not for him doing anything wrong, not because
his ratings were bad, but they literally
fired him because they came to the mob.
Speaker 1: Now, that's completely untrue.
Tucker Carlson caused a multi-hundred million,
if not multibillion dollar problem for Fox News.
Fox News made this decision based on money. Not
only was Tucker's program partially responsible
for the news coverage that got them sued by
Dominion and Smartmatic and so far led to a
nearly $800 million lawsuit settlement, rather,
in favor of dominion. He also is being sued by
a former staffer for alleged discrimination and
sexism and so on and so forth behind the scenes.
He potentially will have caused another lawsuit
by Ray Epps that may be forthcoming. This was
a financial thing, but that's not the
focus of this segment. It's Marjorie's
misunderstanding of the First Amendment.
Speaker 2: What we're seeing is we're
seeing the end of the First Amendment. That's
how we got it. I can't see it any other way.
We've seen censorship out of control. We we saw
the federal government, Department of Homeland
Security align with big tech to censor Americans
for several years now on political issues because
they weren't speaking the speech. That was
the chosen speech to say. Well, neither was
Tucker Carlson. Tucker Carlson was pushing the
limit every single night on his show, and he was
telling the news stories that the American people
wanted to hear. I also want to point out that many
Democrats even watch Tucker Carlson. Okay.
Speaker 1: So the question here is,
is there any way in which a company company
firing an employee could violate the First
Amendment the way Marjorie Taylor GREENE
says the First Amendment of the Constitution
to the Constitution protects individuals? And in
theory, companies as well, from government actions
that interfere with freedom of speech, religion,
press, assembly and petition. Private companies.
Private companies are not bound by the First
Amendment in the same way. And on the other hand,
they also generally have the right to set their
own rules and policies. This is something that
people like Marjorie Taylor GREENE on the right
claim to revere as one of the highest goals and
virtues of the United States legal system.
And this applies to employment as well. Now,
could firings be illegal? Sure. There's all sorts
of wrongful termination that that can and often is
argued by by employees. If Tucker were to be fired
because he's white or because he's Christian,
certainly he would have a very good case for
wrongful termination. I don't believe it would
have anything to do with the First Amendment.
It would violate employer nondiscrimination law.
But the idea that because they fired Tucker,
the First Amendment has been violated merely
because Tucker spoke on TV is ridiculous. It's
ridiculous. And it shouldn't even be. The sad
thing is that we have to explain it in this way.
Now, is there any way is there any way where a
company could be violating the First Amendment
rights of an employee? Imagine that an employee
speaks out about a matter of public concern as a
citizen, and their speech isn't related to their
job duties in any way. You can try to argue that
your First Amendment rights were violated. It's
very tough to do if it's a government job. It's
slightly easier to do, but it's a tough it's
a tough standard to reach. Some states have laws
that protect employees above and beyond the First
Amendment. Like, for example, some states have
laws that prohibit employers from retaliating
against employees for political activity outside
of work. So that would be a situation where there
is an additional protection and the employee would
be able to hold their employer to account. Do any
of these circumstances even remotely apply to
Fox News firing Tucker Carlson? Not Absolutely
not. Absolutely not. And so we are faced once
again with this question. Do right wingers not
actually know what the First Amendment does and
what it is, or do they know but they realize
their followers don't, and so they blatantly lie
to them on TV. I don't know. You be the judge,
but what we do know is Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is humiliatingly wrong here.